What if the very thing that makes you
good at caring for others is slowly
destroying your health? That constant
vigilance comes with a price most never
see coming. We're experiencing a hidden
epidemic called human giver syndrome.
It's when some people give endlessly
without requiring anything in return.
Think about your typical day. The friend
needing support, the family member
requiring help.
Each situation seems manageable, but
collectively it's like dozens of apps
running in the background, each draining
your battery. Here's a truth that might
surprise you. Caring about everything
means effectively caring about nothing.
Your body keeps score even when your
mind ignores it. Those headaches, that
fatigue, they're your body's desperate
attempt to get your attention. The world
doesn't need more martyrs who care until
they break. It needs wholehearted people
who've discovered how to care deeply
while remaining fully alive.